hello hello hi happy to meet you do you
remember when you saw it all the way
through for the first time and the first
thing you thought
quite kind of out there isn't it and
then you came up behind me as we were
walking up and said correct me if I'm
wrong
but is that the most psychotic thing
we've ever been in did I say that
singers that really is Andrew Lincoln's
handwriting on those cards that hat is
covering a pimple on Keira Knightley's
forehead and as for Hugh Grant's dance
scene that's now a viral sensation on
Tick Tock it almost didn't happen
follow my love I saw it in the script
and I thought well I'll hate doing that
I didn't fancy doing the dance at all
let alone rehearsing it he was grumpy
but he knew it was a contractual
obligation I'm out of rhythm by the way
especially at the beginning when I
wiggle my ass I will get myself this
credit it was my idea to have that as
secretary lady catch me genius I was 10.
so where are they now scene stealer
Olivia Olson is now 30 and has released
three albums Thomas Brody Sangster most
recently appeared in the Queen's Gambit
are the tickets paid for it's really
quite quite cool and amazing of course
ET was with the entire cast of the
London Premiere in 2003. I think it's my
first Cutting Edge film lots of laughs
and extremely romantic I should think
it's a
a kind of feel-good Christmas Escape
film it's an irresistible movie
excuse me for one second
[Music]
Diane Sawyers the laughter and secrets
of Love Actually airs tomorrow on ABC
Love Actually is all around all around
dead
[Music]